okay it's a place I came here with a
main man Donald Trump we are back to
doing a railroad quests so since we beat
the game plays like talking since you
beat the game now we're tracking down
basically like gangs so we just
completed mission 1 and now we're going
to mission 2 3 4 and 5 and 6 you paid
off maybe not I had to wait a sec oh
[ __ ] what's this kind of yeah we did
that yeah Institute's gone since save
and we're both alive so what's the
Encore whisper say my sense baby you're
still gonna of course some dusty old
philosophy okay I'll take one of these
missions hey Doc oh good you're here
there's been a development a reader gang
has captured one of our agents codenamed
blackbird the twist is we thought he was
already killed and Augustus safe house
Desdemona clings to the far-fetched hope
that a blackbird is alive and be he can
tell us so she wants you didn't if black
birds on as you see fit the dead drop
has the full briefing laters right okay
butchers belt out so let's do this let's
do this and good good good ah what a
beautiful morning it's a grave it's so
great I got some horrible breath I too
had some a salad oh look a [ __ ] is
yelling like that oh oh [ __ ] sorry what
is all this radiation I can't match
[ __ ] this gun can tame for [ __ ] huh can
you finish a lot thank ya thank ya okay
here we got the drop off [ __ ] his hat I
got it I got it now I gotta find a Jeb
blackbird okay uh he's got the safe
house I oh [ __ ] like that check my camel
toe and like two tents you think there
were more tips with all his arms it's
okay though okay
[ __ ] this guy's going to finish them up
before I can't sorry
[ __ ] he is not gonna win that battle is
he
where's the laces I use my parole
because I care okay is that the answer
you wanted oh yeah oh yeah good good
good they call me the hunter
I hit thank ya thank ya thank ya mmm
don't I have a what is the over man's
words that out war is ours here it is
good get there was a nice little stash I
hear the heck you're gonna take this a
little baby expert up plays nice good
good good yeah you know what this I'll
take I'll gladly take a lot video it's
just [ __ ] language I'm gonna be
right over there to fix your ass I call
down okay how do I look great what is
this [ __ ] got it how many [ __ ] say is
all right here in this game okay
that's it oh shut sorry okay okay and
I'll write their hitter either here yeah
baby yeah if I get it up rarity [ __ ] is
he dead
shook up over nothing
Oh [ __ ] a
that there's more okay
okay well he don't make it sound hey oh
that's awkward yeah earth is a powerful
drug that's all i gotta say it is a
powerful powerful drug oh [ __ ] isn't
there that [ __ ] be still out there I
got I it's gonna suck deck holes can we
like if you had a dick alone he's just
started sort of tongue in there my god
it's not that clean it had to be honest
like you know they say it's sterile
would find a lot of dirt dickholes okay
okay let's just see what does hope this
[ __ ] monsters gone okay it's loading
this is horrible i hate loading saimin
swingman hello John apply this game I've
made too much money for a loading screen
okay okay
oh maybe I can see travel now things all
over there [ __ ] yes I hands on a good
dog
okay wake up a check out the survivor
from augusta Blackbird is dead I didn't
find any evidence of where the synth is
as I expected well wow that's right i
used you won't hood hello anyway thanks
so much